さて、みんなここでドガンしたので
、今日はまったく違う
スタイルのビデオをやっています。これは
私の現在の日本のスタジオのスタジオツアーになります。
ええと、これは
私が約1年前に言いたいこのようなビデオを作りました
が、
それ以来、スタジオは大きく変わりました。最近
このデスクを購入しました。とても満足
し
ていたので、このビデオのスポンサー
になることに興味があるかどうかを確認するために、会社に連絡しました。
彼らが後援しているので、このビデオの後半でこのデスクについて詳しく説明します。その
前
に、ドアの近くから始め
て、電話を持っていないので、他のさまざまなことについて話すことができます。
このカメラの上に適切なマイクを置い
てください。おそらく最初に
疑問に思う
のは、これが何である
かということです。壁が完全に黒く
、実際には
サウンドシートであるため、天井を見上げると
、 親切  標準の
あなたはあなたが買うことができるアマゾンフォームパネルを知っています
私はあなたが100のようなもののためにこれらのかなり大きなパネルの16かそこらを手に入れることができると思います
がそれらは吸収
するのにひどく良い仕事
をしません オーディオ
と私が最近
録音しているときに私が意識しなければならないすべての種類のこと
は、
私が双子の娘を眠らせている私の子供
が部屋で昼寝をしている間に録音することでした
すぐ隣にあるので、私は実際に
壁を
専門的に防音しましたが
、それはつまり、音は
その部屋にあまり入り
ませんが、この部屋にあるエコーを取り除くことはない
ので、取り除くために その中で
、私は最初に
これらのマットを使ってみました。これらのマット
はすべて
天井の向こう側にあることがわかります。
それは大丈夫でした
が
、友人の東京レンズの基準では十分ではありませんでした。 東京の
レンズ
から彼はこれらのええとサウンド
シートを持っています私もええと思います そして彼
は私がそれらをチェックしてみるように勧めた
ので私はそれらを購入しました
そしておそらくあなたがおそらく
部屋全体
がこれらのシートですべての壁が閉じ
られているのを見ることができるのであなたはこのiphoneオーディオだけではあまりよく分からないかもしれません
が まるで
ここで死んでいるようです。
エコーはまったくなく
、地面にもカーペットが敷かれているので、撮影中に
娘が目を覚まさなくなった
ので、象徴的な背景を維持したかったのは明らかです。
見えるかもしれませんが、
そこを見上げる
と、壁の上部にフック
があり、シートがそれらからぶら下がっています。
それ
に加えて、
このパネルがここにあります。 十分な大き
さなので、前
に立ってカメラで
向こうから撮影して
いると、通常の壁の前に立っているように見えます
が、実際に
は小さな切り欠きのようなものです。
その上に本がある
ので多分何y これでできるのは
、
このようなデスクのセットアップにカメラを向けて、ビデオを撮影して
いるときに人々がどのように見えるかを確認できるようにすることです。
エルガトを持っています。これはマルチではなくマルチと呼ばれていると思います。
マルチマウント
今は正確な名前を思い出せませんが
、
このポールを取り付けることができるこのベースプレート
があり、カメラを取り付けてから、
このシングルを
非常に大きくしています。
フラップジャック
フォトディオは名前かもしれませんが、リンク
は以下に提供されますが、
私はここにこのライトを持っています、そしてこれは
かなり大きいのでそれ
をオンにすることができますそしてそれと
ライトアップを持っているときそれは私をかなりよく照らします
天井に上げて、これ
が基本的なセットアップのようなものです。私の
友人は、元のバージョン
の黒い魔法のポケットシネマカメラで撮影している
ので、
通常はデスクに接続されているものを2つ持っ
ています。 セットアップ撮影
と
、YouTubeコメディーをやっているときに私を撮影するもう1つのカメラ
ビデオ私のマイクは
ブルーイエティですそれはちょうど標準的なブルーイエティusbマイクのようなものです
が、私はいつも
このマイクで良い経験をしたので
、私のデスクのマイクも
ブルーイエティです
そして私が撮影するとき私が撮影するとき 私の
ビデオをここに置いて
いたのですが、Macbook
Proを非常に長い
間使用していたので、画面の外からスクリプトを読み取る
ことに加えて、顔のこの部分を明るく
しました。 ここですが、最近は
代わりにipadを使用したので、
線を覚えてカメラに伝えます。
振り返ってみると
、ビデオが完成するまでこれを行います。
基本的にはこれです。
コルグスタンド古いアパートのミュージシャンのために設計されていると思います
実際にやるのは、仕事
を真剣に受け止める前にコンピューターをテーブルに置いたままに
して、ラインを見て考えてみる
ことです。 それから戻ってきて
それを言ってみてそれを忘れ
てそれから私のコンピュータに戻っ
て これは私が100を知らないのに十分な価値があったの
か、それとも
今
は少し時間
をかけてこのデスクについて話し
たいの
です。
過去1年間のスポンサー付きビデオのように行われたかもしれません
が、私はこの製品が本当に好きな
ので
、自分のお金でこのデスクを購入
した後、会社に連絡
して、
スポンサー付きのええとビデオを作ることに興味があると言いました 彼らはそうだと言った
ので、私
は幅が約180
センチ
で、これよりもさらに広い標準的な木製の机を使用
していました。
ここに機器がありますが、少し整理した後
、150で逃げることができることに気付きました
が、その机はスタンディングデスクではなく、スタンディングデスク
ではないにもかかわらず、
実際にそこに
座っているだけでもかなりの量がぐらつきました
公正な金額をぐらつくだろう
私は
ここに重い重いimacを持っているので
2um重い義務ええとあなたはそれを何と呼びますか
vesaマウントアダプター私はこの
elgatoベースプレートを持っ
ています私はこれを持っています私はここにこの重いライトを持っています
私は私のプレイステーションを持っています
コンピューターでタイプしているだけでエルガトキーが点灯しているので
、机がぐらつくことが
あります。この机
は、この110の立った状態でも、立って
いるときに使用する設定
です。
私のコンピューターで作業し
ていますが、ぐらつくと少し
ぐらつき
ますが、コンピューターで入力しているだけでは、
基本的にぐらつきはありませ
ん。これがぐらつく場合
は、安定性が非常に重要でした。
何かが落ち
たら、それは私のビジネスに大きな打撃を与えます。夜や娘が寝ているときに仕事をしているので、静か
なスタンディングデスクを手に入れ、
購入した場所であるアマゾンのすべてのレビューを入手することが重要でした。 この
机はmoを使うと静かになります
トーア
とあなたはおそらく
それがどれほど静かであるかを聞くことができるか、あるいはあなたは聞くことができないかもしれません、そして
私は
おそらくこの部屋の外でこれを
聞くことができるとは思いません
非常に静かで、予想よりも静かで
、この
最低設定または最低設定
である72センチメートル
から115センチメートルまでは、約10秒しかかかりません。これも、自転車に
乗っているときに使用する高さです。
夜にこのスタンディングデスクのクールな点の1つ
は、デザインを選択できることです。
これは実際には本物の木ではなく、本物の木のように見えます
が、テクスチャは
実際には木のように感じます。ここ
では、机の構造が少しよく見えます。
あなたが見ることができるように、足はかなり広いので、
実際に
それらが含まれているこれらの小さなケーブルクリップを
鋼に対して置くことができます、そしてあなた
は木製の机ではそれをすることができないでしょう
すべてのtをドリルするのが好き
これらの穴
とケーブル管理は本当に
本当に大変でした。なぜなら、
ここですべてをクリップで留めること
ができるから
です。
立って作業しているとき、または座っ
て作業
しているときは、ケーブルを見ることさえできません。 何も見えません私
は
ここに2x4のように
木片を
持っています
そのような机な
ので、私はそのような木片を2つ持っています、
そして私はちょうど私のコンセントを持っていますえ
えと、私のパワーエクステンションストリップをそれに対して上に向けてストリップ
します。
人々が言う
ように、私がyoutubeの喧噪をやろうとしていたとき、非常に長い間適切に自分の世話をしていませ
んでしたが、そのため
、1時間以上座って
動かない場合は本当に痛いです。 私が行うすべての作業
は、基本的にコンピューターの前で行われます。
座って、
ベビーシッターが今のようにここにいるので、
私にとって大きな問題になりました。ついに仕事に取り掛かろうとしましたが、
耐えられなかったので、1時間後に仕事をやめなければなりませんでした。 もう座る
ことができたので、基本的には30分間
働くことを心配する必要はありません。
その後、立ち上がっ
て30分間働きます。
自転車に乗って、遊んでみ
てください。 ファイナルファンタジー7の30分
と私が実際にアマゾンジャパンでこれを見つけた理由の1つは、
これが180センチメートルまで上がるオプション
があった数少ない机の1つであり、
先に述べたと思いますが
、私の古い机は 180センチなので
スタンディングデスクも180センチ必要だと思ったのです
が
、整理してみる
と150で逃げられることに気づきました。
これを作った会社は
デイジーンコギルと呼ばれ
、1000ドルくらいだったと思います。
なぜなら、基本的にすべてカスタムメイドだから
です e
さまざまな幅とさまざまなデザインのさまざまなレイアウトから選択できる
ので、アマゾン
から購入した場合、注文した日からここに到着するまでに約3週間かかりました。
それを贈り物
のように選択し、メッセージセクションの
メッセージセクションのよう
に、デザインの名前と脚の色を書きます。デザインでは、
ここでもパネルが上にある色を意味します。
多くの多くの
オプションがありますが
、私
がそれを購入した後、会社は再び連絡を取り、
これがあなたが望むものであると確信
しています
か？ 私は自分で作るのが苦手です。
物を壊す傾向があります
が、これをまとめるのは大丈夫
でした。それほど難しくはなく
、他の多くのものとは異なり、
かなり難しいものでした。 大きいか私の
古い机のように
パッケージングも
、私が机について言いたい最後の種類の1つを圧倒していませ
んでした。彼らは
、スマートフォンと
スマートフォンのアプリをリンクする新しいバージョンを作成して
いるようです。
立ち上がる必要がある
か、
立ちたい目標分数は
、確認ボタンを押した後、アプリケーション内からも
上下させることができるので、机の真上にいくつかのコンセントがあると思います。
後ろに見えるようにケーブルを通すことができる小さな穴がいくつかあるわけではありませんが、私は
実際に物事をきれいに保つようにしていますので
、机の上にコンセントを持たないことを好みますこの机
は素晴らしいものでした 日本
に住んでいる人は誰でもこの机をチェックすることを強くお勧め
します。最近の私の何かを見たことがあるかどうか知っているように、仕事をしているときにもう痛みがないので、私の作業環境は無限に快適になります。
あなたの日本のビデオに影響を与えるこれは
私がこれにフィリップスの色相ライトを持っているそれらのビデオの背景設定です
そしてこれは
私たちがビジネスのようなランプにいるように卵黄の噛み物です
そして私はここに寿司のサインを持っています
私のyoutubeプラークを手に入れました。元気
いっぱいのカラナシを手に
入れました。最近、このファイナルファンタジーviiを舞台裏で手に入れました。これは
、本の
ファイナルファンタジー7をリメイクし、
オリジナルが
私のお気に入りです。 ゲームこれまで私は
そのゲームから一般的な生活について多くを学びました
これは一種の雑学です
おそらく数人だけ
がこれを拾いましたが
、このランプはここにありますええと
これは実際には元のドーゲンなので
、
禅仏教の僧侶は誰ですか
彼が作ったお寺です彼はソウル東京の
ソルトゼンと呼ばれる禅の宗派を作りました
そして私
は高校でそれについて多くを学びました私は
日本や学校の段階についてのようなものでした
そして私
はこの種の別の仏教禅に入りました
仏教フェーズa
さて、私は同じuhメーカーによって作られたこれらの本棚のうちの2つ
を一番上
に持っています、それはほとんどケーブルと
そこにあるようなものですそしてそれから私は私の重要な
税務書類と保険証書のようなものを持っています
そのようなものと
私は私のipadを持ってい
ます私はすべての日本の音声学の本から私のスクリプトを読みました
これらはすべて基本的に
すべて日本語の発音に関する本
なので、
私が日本語を勉強していたときに得た知識に加えて
コ大学での発音と高低アクセント、
そして
明らかに私がこの時点で日本に住んでいる10年以上は、
パトレオンで再び取り上げられる日本語の音声学のレッスンを作成するときに、これらの本の多くを参照し
ます。
今、私の机の上にいます。
プレイステーション4が
ここにあります。
これは中古のプレイステーション4
で、ファイナルファンタジー7リメイクを再生するために特別に購入し
ました。
ビデオゲームのようにプレイ
することが私の考え方の一種であることがわかるように、プレイステーションを取得するために250ドルのような費用をかける価値があります
が、
そのゲームが私にとってどれほど重要であるかを忘れていたので、
これについて言及したと思います たぶんツイッチ
か
、過去にやったyoutubeライブストリームで、私は
そのゲームを起動し、ゲーム
のイントロビデオの1分ほどで泣き叫ぶようなものでした。
基本的に週に3回
運動するので、このエクササイズバイクをここに
置いておきます。これはフレキシスポットです。
基本的にこのモニターに向けてセットアップし
、デスクをもう少し上げて
ファイナルをプレイします。 ファンタジー7日本語で
私のバイクに乗っている間あなたがお父さんであるときあなたは
残念ながら
基本的に時間がありません
特にあなたが双子の双子の娘を持っているときあなたが
若いなら
私は2025のようですそれはおそらくそれほど
大きな問題ではありません
しかし、非常に
健康上の問題は本当に傾向があります
私のような多く
のクリエイター
は、おそらく健康にあまり注意を払っていない
ので、このスタンディングバイク
や、申し訳ありませんが、このスタンディングバイクやこのデスクの下に
ある スタンディング
デスクこれら
は、多くのクリエイターにとって本当に重要な投資だと思います。
デスクのセットアップビデオを撮影するとき
、あなたの日本人に反応するとき
、友人が持っているカメラから撮影しますが、
それはこのエルガトマルチに付属してい
ます- マウントして、
このビデオを撮影する予定だった彼のカメラを取り付け
ました。これは、エルガトキーライトと呼ばれるものを持っているように見えるようにするためです
。 私
に照明を当てるのは本当に良い仕事
ですもう1つ
簡単に触れておきたいの
は、カメラの内側にあるsdカードに記録していること
です。私のワークフローにはさまざまな部分があり
ます。
何かが起こるのを待たなければならない一般的なワークフローなので
、ビデオがレンダリングされるのを待たなければならないかもしれません。
ビデオのエクスポートが完了
するのを待たなければならないかもしれません。映像をインポートするのを待たなければならないかもしれません。
私は
いつもカメラからコンピューターにビデオをインポートするのに最も長く待た
なければなりませんでした。約1時間録画すると、
60ギガバイトまたは70ギガバイトのファイル
が残り、それをコンピューターに転送するために
あなたは標準的なええと小さなアダプターを知っています、
それは
たくさんの研究をした後にしばしば20分かかるでしょう
私
はこのことについて学びましたこれは
ウルトラスタジオレコーダー3gと呼ばれて
いますそれはちょうどこの小さな箱のようなものですそして
それは本質的に
あなたが接続する単なるキャプチャカードです
カメラ
からこの小さなボックスへのhdmi出力なので
、コンピューター用のサンダーボルトケーブルを入手しました。
これをキャプチャカードに
接続するだけで、ファイルを直接記録できます。
記録を打ち終えるとすぐに
ファイルがすでにデスクトップにあるので、
それを
節約するようなコンピュータは、ビデオごとに約20分の作業を
節約し
ます。これは、撮影した場合、複数年の作業にわたって多くの時間を節約できます。
外出し
てVlogのようなこと
をするのではなく、キャプチャカードを使用
すると、ワークフローが大幅にスピードアップする可能性があるので、
基本的にすべてをカバーしたと
思います。
質問がある場合は、ここでビデオを終了します。
以下にコメントを残し
てください。今後ともよろしくお願いいたし
ます。またお話しします。
次の動画でまたお会いしましょう。
通常の
コメディー動画とは少し異なります。
楽しいひねりのようですが、
それはみんなにとって驚きになるので、
またすぐに会いましょう
[音楽]